this is the truth so it had to be done i
wanted to postpone it actually to uh
the end of the year i was like you know
what if what if i die
you know i wasn't really planning to you
know tell
like people because i knew this was very
shocking like my background
like just looking at it
like super christian you know i mean she
eventually saw me you know doing prayers
doing a slot she saw me
you know doing that and uh
this really outraged her a lot man she
said you know you didn't think it
through you didn't you know she said a
lot of things man and at that point man
i i really couldn't
you know get to her you know how you
know like she was so filled up with
emotion it wasn't like anything i said
wouldn't register i didn't know it was
gonna get to the point where she told me
like well you can't you know you can't
practice islam under my roof basically
what she told me i don't know what allah
is fine for me and i'm gonna continue
searching that man but i know one thing
for sure
allah will be with me throughout this
journey man i'll i will provide so
i'm not i'm not too concerned man you
know
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
welcome back to the realest podcast in
the dunya the three muslims we are
joined here with a very special guest
a new recent river to islam although he
looks like he's been muslim all his life
masha allah salaam alaikum
alaikum salaam brothers
bro so what you see right now is is your
muslim name right but your real name is
dalton
yes
this is my name uh
that i chose from like muslim do you
want us to refer to you as dalton or
uthman whichever works for you guys
whichever works for you i don't know
this one that works for me
so what does it mean uh
well so i actually
read like i was reading the quran and i
read that uh one of the prophet's cousin
uthman and
i kind of liked his story a little bit
man and a barakah means a blessed one so
i feel blessed so you know that's why
without further ado let me let me get
out the chat let me change my uh name to
the arabic name that i got
this man all right so in the meantime
while he comes back in the intermission
i want you to quickly start your revert
story
tell us everything bro tell us about how
you grew up where you are
um
what you followed growing up by your
family and how long you've been muslim
bro go into it all
all right bismillah bismillah
um so
just recently not too long ago
um i actually just you know reverted to
islam
um i believe this was about uh
right after my birthday so my birthday
was september 10
and uh about uh three days later um i
was like
you know i think i think this is a move
to uh
to uh you know convert
i had been thinking about this for a
long time because prior to this
um in my country you know there's like a
good percentage of uh muslims so it's
about like a 50 50 percentage i'm from
tanzania originally
and uh
you know i've kind of grown up seeing
like the muslim community over there so
it wasn't something new
and uh
it came up to me very recently like um
around 2019 2020 during the pandemic
where i've actually had the time to
you know
really get into you know
islam and you know read about it and and
kind of obviously i'm still in the
learning stages so i don't i'm not
really
you know i can't say oh you know i know
this but
for me just took time to listen to the
quran and now i'm reading it again to uh
to say this is the truth so it had to be
done i went to postponing actually to uh
the end of the year
i was like you know
what if what if i die
you know
the next day or in a week before
december you know i mean it would be a
shame if uh
you know i didn't take that decision so
i'm
glad i'm here
so uh tell us how you were introduced to
islam
uh
what am i
by the way you you grew up in the states
well okay so i was born in tanzania but
i moved to united states when i was uh
about 12 years old so uh yeah you can
say i grew up here i'm about 24 right
now
so you know
you know half and half so i grew up 12
years 12 years here
so both
i had both of the influence both of my
countries um
i'll say the way i was introduced
there's this one guy i don't know if you
guys follow mma
by the name of khabib nugget
normal gomez
one of my
you know i
i train mma and uh i see this guy the
way you carry himself you know the way
he you know
you know treats people the way he
conducts himself in public
you know mashallah and i'm like you know
that guy is amazing and you know
every time when he gets interviewed
sometimes i ask him about his islam
he's never afraid to you know talk about
it
his religion and you can tell like
this is a big part of part of his life
and he doesn't let all the other noise
kind of
affect
you know how you know
he should interact with people so
i'll say that's one of
he his his story and kind of his
background allowed me to
to kind of gauge the the interest first
and then uh
the rest was just me kind of going by
myself i didn't really talk to anybody
in person
i think when i started listening to the
quran
i ran to a few people a couple of
friends of mine
who have friends of mine now
that kind of enhance that experience but
i'll say habib definitely
you know
you know be began that uh you know
that uh
i guess journey
[Laughter]
tell me a little bit about uh or tell
the viewers about what you were telling
me last night that uh
your first experience with islam it
wasn't actually reading something but it
was something else
i think
um
could you like refresh my memory a
little bit about about you listening to
a recitation for the first time
okay great thank you thank you thank you
yeah man so
um
obviously my you know i'm always
constantly like i listen to adam all the
time i feel like that's like
you know adam recitations i'm always
constantly listening to this
you know when i wake up sometimes uh i
listen to it now i've gotten to the
point where you know i actually enjoy
you know
kind of in remembering and trying to
recite it and i'll just find myself like
you know the villain
bismillah
rahim
stuff like that so
you know
yeah man so uh you know
yeah let's that's that
marshall mashallah
all right so uh
bro pause before you continue you know
what's crazy
you know like sometimes you look at
something and then you just kind of zone
out and you just kind of but like
looking at the person and then like the
background just kind of like
blends
you're not really focused on the
background you focus on the person
but right now
as like i'm talking to you and i'm
looking at you like your hat
is uh blending in with the background
and then it almost looks like a little
face just like
cropped in there like you know on
snapchat you can just like have like
this random thing and then like crop
your face in mm-hmm
that's what i'm seeing when i'm talking
to the brother right now i just had to
throw it out that was
marshall bro i feel that i feel that you
can see the note on his face right like
the the glow it's real
yeah i mean i don't have chest uh i
guess i don't yeah yeah yeah well it's
i don't know how to explain it it's like
well they would have like some random
little animation and then you can just
like plug your little photo in there and
then it'll show your face with the
animation
yeah that's what i that's what it looks
like right now
don't don't get snapchat and definitely
don't add another on snapchat
you won't you won't be getting the the
weirdest snaps bro
marshall i love my body bro but uh that
aside bro
growing up in the west in america
america bro you've got all these
misconceptions about islam
yeah the fox news narrative
parents sometimes i want to see the
brainwash but they kind of fall into
this trajectory a little bit so how has
your parents your family how have they
taken it
bro oh man
this is uh
you know
obviously very recently you know i go
like
so today is what october 7th right so
that will be not just yeah eighth right
so it's coming up on a week so almost a
month so it's like three weeks right now
and uh
you know i wasn't really planning to you
know tell
like people because i knew this was very
shocking like my background
like just looking at it
like super christian you know i mean i'm
talking about
on my my dad's side everybody is
christian there
my mom's side everybody is christian
there so you know um i had an aunt of
mine and you know she told me that
you know in your journey this is going
to be something shocking so
um
you kind of just
keep it low right now just keep doing
you
get get get to know the dean and and
that was kind of my approach
however you know how how long can you go
like that you know i mean so eventually
you know i was here at my house and uh
you know my sorry my my mom's house
excuse me and uh
you know she she eventually saw me you
know doing prayers doing a slot she saw
my uh
um we call it the the prayer mat um
i don't know how you call it in english
but uh she saw she saw me uh
you know doing that and uh
this really outraged her a lot man he
really like it was like
she was fired up man and not fired up in
a good way of course no word
she uh definitely saw me like she had
came back from um
you know
from a trip and then she she you know
she saw me she well she saw the mat and
i was trying to rush my way to go grab
the mess so she can't see the pie right
but she had already seen it so she came
but i came there and now and she thought
she asked me so
you know are you muslim
i was like
alhamdulillah
yeah man it was uh
you know i i had to i had to say man i
was like you know yeah you know i am
and uh i could see you know she was very
hurt by this decision
and she said you know he didn't think it
through you didn't you know she said a
lot of things man and
at that point man i i really couldn't
you know get to her you know how you
know women tend to be a lot emotional
and uh
like she was so filled up with emotion
it wasn't like anything i said wouldn't
register
you know i mean so in my head at that
time i was just like
you know i was i was
very calm i'm usually very calm guy i
don't like overreact or anything you
know like even if it's like a lot of
noise i'm kind of just like
you know
some people may say i may have a i smile
a lot but i may have like a poker face
sometimes when i'm you know listening to
somebody right
and uh like slight smile
and uh so she
you know she
she took that as maybe like um it's
everything she um she's saying to me is
not getting through
and uh yeah she's like you know like
what's your family gonna think you know
and my my grandmother is really really
religious catholic like she's always
praying
you know god bless her heart man she's
she's great woman for sure she's a
you know in christianity like for the
people in christianity that would be
like like an example
but uh she's like what if i tell your
grandmother this like
this might kill her you know she she
said like a lot of egregious things man
like and i'm like
you know spinal uh you know god please
make this easy for me at that point you
know what i mean so
um
i didn't say much i just said a few
words man i was like you know
it's not really it was my free will and
nobody really influenced me and this was
kind of my decision
and uh
yeah that's all i said and and you know
she kind of went upon her way and uh she
messaged me like a
um
a couple
days later and she was like we have to
talk
you know we have to speak
and i was like sure you know why not
and uh
actually funny enough i just spoke to
her
so today's uh today's friday i spoke to
her on uh yesterday right thursday after
work
uh
so
i knew it was about to be you know it
was better if i get fired up i knew
something was coming
but i didn't know it was going to be to
the extent where you know she's going to
give me like an ultimatum you know i
mean so i didn't i didn't see that
coming uh it's fine allah but uh you
know i talked to her um
and uh you know she kind of this time
she was even more and more
more emotional like
like
oh my god dalton you don't even care
about me doesn't like you don't even
care how this is gonna affect me and
this you know a lot and
i listened to her man she went on a
barrage for like 15 20 minutes man and i
was completely engaged man i was just
i was listening you know she was saying
like now you put me in danger you know
now you know i i got a call recently
that you know
they asked her theresa made some
documents uh out of work and she's like
i don't know maybe you know and i'm
right now i'm taking some classes on uh
american national security right so
she's like
well with that route you know
they're definitely not gonna you know
you being a muslim you know that's gonna
be like a red flag she said a lot of
things brother a lot a lot of things man
and uh
you know like i said man i'm not really
overreactive guy man so i kind of heard
her out man it's like with that route
you know you'll be
radicalized this and that man and
you know i know myself man i i know who
i am brother i just know
the kind of person i am man and
islam is kind of just a way for me
to be a better version and and do good
deeds man and try to please allah that's
my sole goal man i had to change my
mindset from
trying to do my own thing to really try
and please god so i know in my heart man
this is going gonna pay off long term i
do not really care about you know the
life and
necessarily here in the world because
that's as in the quran
it's fleeting man they always say that
it's about the year after and so i know
like
this was expected to come but
i didn't know it was gonna get to the
point where she told me like well
you can't you know you can't practice
islam under my roof basically what she
told me and she was like
you know um
yeah you can't you know she was getting
annoyed because
i was doing this a lot like after after
i finished that conversation right i
went outside to do my for prayer right
and uh
you know i finished my essay prayed uh
she actually had came downstairs and uh
she saw me
and uh she was like after what we talked
you know you still you still you know
you're still doing this and i was like
mom like
i have to do my daily prayers this is
obligatory like this has to be done
and uh she's like but that's you know
disrespectful this and that and i was
like mom
even in the quran it says
you have to be kind and respectful to
your parents which i'm being i'm being
very kind and respectful
not trying to disrespect you at all
but he says he also says right after
unless they're trying to try to turn you
away
from serving god turn you away from
islam
and by you telling me that
i cannot do my daily prayers
that's kind of what you're doing right
now and you know she started making
comparisons you know against
non-practicing muslims he's like even
the muslims i i reached out to about
this you know they they don't pray five
times a day and i'm like
can i at least speak to those guys are
you speaking to because
in the quran it's clearly says this is
part that
there's
the recommended prayers and there's you
know the obligate
prayers which is five times a day
this has to be done so just because
they're not doing it does not
necessarily mean it's the right thing to
do
you know what i'm saying and she just
didn't understand it and
you know um
may allah have mercy on her um you know
because i i i i still love and care for
her a lot man and i've been spending a
lot of time
really praying for her and uh because i
know it's just ignorance at this point
you know it's it's she just doesn't
understand the religion so um
may allah make it easy for him i think
in inshallah life it's in god's will um
you know she opened her eyes to the
truth one day and and
you know she'll know what's up my ain't
shelby
that's tough man but it's
it's really just emotional like you said
and it's
it's ignorance
and it's it's it's misunderstanding bro
because like walla when i became muslim
and i told my mom i remember was in the
car
and we were driving to a supermarket and
i was like
she slammed the brakes on the car
and then she was like
what
bro she started popping off saying
the most ridiculous things bro saying
like oh
like how can you do this you're going to
be labeled a terrorist like don't don't
tell anyone that you're muslim because
then you're just going to be you're
going to be on the hit list or whatever
it was and she's like i can't believe
you're doing this i'm like
listen all the things that you're saying
right now
it's all misunderstandings
you have to if you want to know the
truth i can tell you or i can show you
and to this day she hasn't really asked
me about it or she hasn't asked to see
it it's like she just
kind of let me be
but it's um women are emotional though
in that sense
bro
okay when you said that your mom isn't
gonna let you practice islam under her
roof what does that even mean bro
well i do i just
lit i i just can't like i have to be you
know
she said
she literally told me like yesterday
you wanna you wanna you wanna do that go
to that guy who who who converted you
and practice at their house so she told
me
you know i mean so and uh
you know so she basically i can't you
know anywhere around this place i just
can't
she can't see me
i just want to know what the big deal is
like
what's what's so
ground shattering
that she
she can't have you practice islam
and she can't have you submit to god
that she can't have you pray
under her roof like what what's
what's really the the main reason you
like what's going on like what if i was
you i'd try to find like that that root
cause that's like why she's
acting in this way
well brother i i think i know i know
what it is man like
and uh i'll just be real with you man in
the past i definitely you know put my
mom through some stuff man i ain't gonna
lie to you bro i mean so
in the past i was kind of
and just recently starting like 2020 man
when i actually began this
spiritual journey man and eventually
made this decision to to come to islam
and i put my mom through some ups and
downs right and you know and at points
when i used to even not even talk to her
brother you know i'm saying like and so
she may have some
you know trauma based on that man
because
i was going through some stuff of my own
and i was kind of
putting on her
but i've changed ever since so she feels
like
she even sometimes when she talks she's
like
you know dalton you you always go
against me you know i mean
so she kind of has a
previous trauma in the past so she's
connecting this
to the past although i've been
pretty much more conscious about
everything that i do
you know now and kind of to be a better
man i'm not perfect i'm always always
seeking to to improve every time man so
it was it was just like a shocking blow
and it kind of just reminded her of you
know perhaps like
the way i uh you know things i've done
in the past man but
i said to you in the beginning man
i made a like when i converted to islam
man
i literally i'm an adult man right now
man
i can't
sit here and and act and and you know do
some of the things that i may have done
in the past may have hurt people because
that that's not that's not supporting
islam man
in islam it says
you know even your relatives man
regardless of your relationship with
them you have to kind of maintain that
peace
he tells you this
in islam he said
allah doesn't like the arrogant and the
boastful
it says that so i had to kind of tune my
pride down
you know i mean and
really became if i say i'm gonna be a
muslim
i have to walk the talk man and that was
the whole me and
you know so
just a combination of that man and and
the kind of person i used to be man you
know kind of
hit the nerve man and
you know like i have to show her man
that you know
i'm i'm really trying to be better man
that's my goal bro i just want to serve
my life bro
dude
forget forget what i want bro forget
yeah forget like all this stuff that
you know i did man i made that chance
man i can i can't i can't be
intentionally trying to do wrong
i can't
i have self-awareness now dude
you know like obviously i'm like
i self-awareness since i was young but
now like if you know this is an
egregious thing
if you know you're hurtful to somebody
by doing this
why still do it
i can't i can't live i can't live like
that man so
um
you know when allah got me to repeat
that again yeah if you don't mind
repeat that one more time
yeah man i'm just saying i just can't
if you if you do something that hurts
someone
why would you continue i think that's
something along the lines of what you
said yeah man
yeah
i just can't
if i know something is hurtful
and detrimental to somebody or even
detrimental to myself in my relationship
with allah
then i can't consciously do it
because
remember what the hell
what the quran says allah knows what's
in everyone's hearts
so
you know so you may say like oh you know
maybe try it do some sneaky stuff out
here man but just remember allah knows
what's in your heart
so i i can't i can't really
say that you know
you know try to do stuff that's
you know i'm gonna go against allah man
and call myself a muslim man i don't
want to live that life
and i'm the best man i'm gonna do my
best man
may allah make it easy for you
um i mean so since you since you've
reverted you've been trying to hit all
five daily prayers you know um
we all know guys anyone watching this
doesn't make you an exceptional muslim
this just makes you a muslim like this
is borderline you're not getting brownie
points for this however at the same time
bro mama is always gonna see you as a
little boy this is with all men right no
matter how old you get she was the one
changing a diaper she's the one that
raised you fed you clothed you you know
so to some degree i feel like
being on your own and severing this tie
not in a you know not saying cut your
parents off and go ghost but
being alone and like really taking time
to reflect you know probably something
said that good company is better than no
company
but uh no company is better than bad
company
and often oftentimes it's time that we
take it upon ourselves so
this being said that this is the current
state of what's gonna happen what are
you gonna do bro what's your plan coming
forward because you definitely can't be
around there now practicing islam
yeah man that's a good question man i i
wish i i had like a a well thought out
plan about what i'm about to do in like
three months man but uh
you know i've been really
kind of
really planned it out man i think right
now
um you know alhamdulillah i had some
couple friends uh reached out to me
regarding this and that they said hey
man you can stay here for a week or
whatever and as you as you figure
somehow man so
um i reached out also to my to my coach
i'm still waiting to get back my mma
coach
and uh see you know for me right now i'm
doing a lot um like
i'm not in
like
you know
crazy situation like i'm not there's
some people who have went worse than me
right so um
you know i just need a place where i can
you know at least
you know still still work and and do my
thing um so i think uh a few people have
reached out to me and i'm gonna do that
while i figure something a place to stay
in
and uh inshaallah allah will provide
inshallah love for pride
michelle where are you at phoenix
arizona right yes sir yes sir
okay sounds good guys if any of you are
watching this and you live in the
phoenix arizona area in
america
uh or if you know anyone there that can
help them out either a friend or just
some muslim that can you know he's very
new into islam or
give him a place to stay just hook him
up anyone knows anything hit us up on
instagram at the three muslims or or
email the three muslims at gmail.com um
we gotta we gotta show them what it's
all about show some love in the comments
too cause uh
this is what the dean teaches us all
right love for
your brother what you love for yourself
um aside from that bro what is your
long-term goal because i know short term
it's a little turbulent but what did you
envision long term
right right right yeah that's a good
question man i like that question
um
so as far as my long-term plans man i
uh right now i currently want to you
know do some work in in in you know my
country in tanzania specifically the you
know the youth over there i feel like
very drawn in and called at the same
time man i'm still
in the stage where
i'm still constantly praying and and
seeing if this is our last line for me
because
maybe
you know i'm still trying to distinguish
whether this is the plan for love for me
or you know so i i'm still
one further confirmation here but
um i just want to go there man and work
with the youth over there because i feel
like
um that's the spot you know
that's my calling man i really like
engaging with the you know teaching
people man and and i feel like even now
with islam and i feel like that could be
potentially
an avenue where i could you know you
know given as a continue of growing
knowledge and and
understanding um
eventually kind of work with the with
the you know young people there and and
just
my goal is just to teach them to to to
do the right thing and go to the right
way man so whether that's implementing
islam whether that's implementing taking
care of yourself you know instilling
confidence amongst people or you know
instilling
treating people the right way amongst
this youth in order for them to succeed
uh give them give them some platforms
given that i'm in the us here um i hear
a lot of the youth over there they
always complain to me like hey man it's
really hard it's really challenging so
you know if allah you know blesses me to
be that point where i'm able to afford
them and allow them to
to give me that platform to kind of help
out man and you know i feel like
that will be
a definite
state of fulfillment for me inshallah at
the same time i want to serve allah man
so
we were in class last night
and rami and we were learning uh
how dawah it's it's not something that
we have a choice you know once you
become muslim and you you acknowledge
that this is the the objective truth of
reality
you have to share it bro like the
prophet saw some said convey from me
even if it's one ayah
like
you you don't have to become a scholar
you know what i mean so you know
leading by example and all that we
already have to do it but active dial we
got to do it through our actions
first and foremost no matter what and uh
verbally when we can um aside from that
bro it's 6 a.m so i know we got to wrap
it up but i got one last question for
you real quick how at peace are you now
that you found the truth and you know
it's the truth
well you can see it on him he doesn't
even have to answer that
yeah man oh my god dude
you know
i mentioned to this this to you uh the
evening when i
i talked to yesterday brother but uh
despite you know like
when i was talking to my mom you know
god bless her heart
um
despite her saying all these things man
you know she said a lot man and
i usually you know i
yeah i might cry here and there i i only
cry when i do pray the most of the time
that's when i cry man but uh
you know i actually cried like after i
didn't cry in front of her but i did cry
as i left you know i mean and uh but
when she was telling me all this man i
was like
um the decision was made and i'm really
content like it didn't occur to me like
let me change to appease her
he didn't occur me at any point bro at
any point despite all the noise bro the
noise was
and i was listening to it it's not like
i was ignoring i was listening to
everything
but at any point it did not occur to me
that
i gotta change this man so
um
you know i know it's gonna be a crazy
journey but i'm i'm completely at peace
man and i know
um
you know i don't know what allah has
planned for me and i'm gonna continue
searching that man but i know one thing
for sure allah will be with me
throughout this journey man allah will
provide so i'm not i'm not too concerned
man you know so a lot do you watch what
you got to do if our lives on your side
like
well why should you worry man so
that's it man i'm doing i'm just
i don't know what to say bro yeah i'm
just happy bro it is oh yeah you ain't
got to sing that involved yes sir it
shows on your face man
i don't know you got anything else to
say uh i want to ask you about my name
how long you been doing mma
uh well it's a good question man i
haven't been doing crazy long man i
think uh i started uh
that was a february of uh this year uh
21
i said well
yeah end of january beginning of
february right i started that and uh
man it's uh
it's great man i want to actually get to
a point where you know i'm i'm
you know
i i know exactly how to defend myself
you know obviously we're not trying to
do this to incite any violence but yeah
with self-protection here man in case it
happens man but it's fun when i like
getting there man doing my jiu jitsu man
doing my time
it's great stuff man you do that
yeah yeah
i do it as well so i'm trying to know
exactly what you mean definitely
i'd say for
a little
in total all like condensed in a year
because there were like breaks here and
there no things that came up injury um
yeah injuries or injuries are
something serious
they got stretched
yeah i get that yeah yeah yeah but no in
my case i actually over stressed i was
too ambitious in my stretches
i was too ambitious and then i pulled uh
my my my hip flexor groin area
and um i've just been
healing up since then but
enough and you know not to get about me
but what i wanted to say the last thing
i want to say to you
is i think training
mma is quite possibly like one of the
best forms of
ibada outside of the obligatory things
and outside of like the religious things
because think about this right
what is one of the things that every
single human has inside of them
that like when
uh
of course but i'm i'm referring to like
let's say you're in a situation
where it's a little sus
you know like maybe
you you see this this individual this
group of people instinct
yeah and like something's going on it's
like
you want to be able to defend yourself
so
it's like a part of you if you don't
know how to defend yourself a part of
you has fear
in this situation
and it's like bro at the end of the day
we're only supposed to feel allah
so when someone knows how to defend
themselves like it takes that fear of
the situation or that fear of another
human being away completely because one
you know that you can defend yourself
and two you can rest easy because you
know that allah is the best sustainer
and he's nothing is going to be muhammad
by mistake here
you know and like of course you can say
abu you can have that from the rip that
is true
but if you don't know how to defend
yourself the way that our
minds work the way that our psychology
works
we're probably gonna have some fear
because we don't want to
you know no one wants to be oppressed no
one wants to be
in that situation and be helpless not be
able to do anything in that situation
yeah i couldn't agree more and uh i i
didn't really think
think of it like that bro but uh
now you kind of opened my eyes into into
you know
a different shift in in mindset on how
to view martial arts and i feel like
that will be definitely
i have a greater thing to to to to
pursue
myself well may i like accept it for me
and from you bro cause
that is something recently that has come
to me because before it was just like oh
i wanna i wanna fight i wanna do mma
because i i like doing it it's fun
um but then like when you get real deep
into it like i'm sure it goes way deeper
than that but that's
as much as a lot has revealed to me
so far you know so
amazing all right
with that being said if you guys made it
this far smash that like button
hit us up for more content and
until next time dalton
uthman
it was a pleasure man
for uh making the time to spread your
truth
thanks you guys for having me here
man love reward you guys thank you
there's another thing too it's it's the
perseverance aspect too
like we're more willing to stick through
with things that we set out with an
intention it's impossible to have
empathy for others if you're not patient
so my love bless you for that first of
all i agree with the fact that
the whole thing you said about friends
where it's like if they're affecting you
more than you're affecting them then you
should probably get some new friends
um
[Music]
[Music]